all right and finally new rule you can't
demand that everyone stand for the flag
if you've colluded with a foreign
government to subvert the very democracy
that flag represents
the Russia scandal is complicated and
that makes a lot of people shrug it off
so we thought tonight we would do what
every other crime investigator does
these days at least not every cop show
and serial killer movie I ever saw we
made one of these ah nice job
so the crime were tracking starts in the
90s with this man Donald Trump aka fat
Donnie aka Donnie retweets aka
Edward baby hands a string of
bankruptcies had made fat Donnie a
deadbeat on the street but somehow he
keeps getting money from somewhere but
where well according to this man
Don Trump jr. aka Donnie douchebag aka
the [ __ ] that didn't fall far from
the tree he said Russians make up a
pretty disproportionate cross-section of
our assets an admission corroborated by
this man his brother Eric Shortbus from
[Applause]
aka tweedledumber who tells his golfing
buddies we don't rely on American banks
we have all the funding we need out of
Russia bingo Sarah Palin might see
Russia from her house but Trump could
see it from his bank account and that's
when he decided he was bored with milani
and ready to [ __ ] someone new America
meanwhile on the other side of the world
this man ex-kgb agent Vladimir Putin aka
Vlad II bats aka the bad father is
looking to install a stooge in the
country he still hates but who who's
desperate and dumb enough and so
according to the steel dossier Putin
reached into his old bag of KGB tricks
to compromise Trump not just with the
bank loans but by secretly filming him
with this woman Ivana golden shower and
her and her fellow prostitute Natasha
urine cost extra
[Applause]
consider them armed and hydrated cut to
2014 Lodi bats invades Ukraine which
causes a US President Barack Obama and
his consigliere Hillary Hillary Clinton
aka hot sauce ill aka The Nutcracker to
impose crippling economic sanctions on
Russia which scuttles
a multi-million dollar deal for Black
Sea oil between Russia and ExxonMobil
who headed ExxonMobil at the time and
received Russia's medal of friendship
this man our current Secretary of State
Rex I drink your milkshake Tillerson
coincidence
I think net Vladdy bats doesn't like his
oil deal going south so he does what
Russians do when they want something
fixed in Washington he pays millions to
this man Paul Manafort aka Paulie
numbnuts
aka slime shady currently under
investigation by every agency in the
u.s. except William Morris and for good
reason he's so far up Putin's ass he can
taste his lunch
so it raised eyebrows when one day out
of nowhere he becomes campaign manager
for fat Donnie even offers to do the job
for free although word on the street is
someone was paying and here's a
coincidence Paulie numbnuts used to be
partners in a lobbying firm with fat
Donnie's albino assassin Roger stone who
happens to be Twitter pals with goose'
fur AKA russian intelligence and they've
been hacking the Democratic Party's
private emails and sending them to this
man WikiLeaks founder and Hillary hater
Julian Assange aka gay Richard Branson
[Applause]
on October 7 2016 at 103 p.m. the famous
Access Hollywood tape is leaked which
should have been phat Donnie's ticket to
Mitt Romney Vil but twenty nine minutes
later WikiLeaks announces it suddenly
came across a trove of DNC emails and
releases the first two thousand every
intelligence agency in America says the
hack came from Russia but our president
who supposedly is defending our country
doesn't agree and says it could be
anybody could be the work of a fat guy
on their bed yeah a lot of things could
be like the meeting Johnny douchebag set
up with eight Kremlin connected Russians
in the middle of the campaign that he
said was about adoptions could be except
it wasn't an email turned up address -
Donnie promising very high-level and
sensitive information that is part of
Russia and its government's support of
mr. Trump little Donnie's response I
love it because he's a [ __ ] idiot
also at that meeting Paulie numbnuts and
fat Donnie son-in-law
Jared the Jew Kushner aka silent Jared
aka baby [ __ ]
Jarrid also needs Russian money to cover
bad bet so he meet secretly with the
Russian spy master I mean ambassador
Sergei kiss lyac aka big potato a
meeting which also includes this man
Michael Flynn aka Mikey headcase who had
accepted buckets of cash to advise
Russia and oh yeah then served as
national security adviser to fat Donnie
a position he had to resign after being
caught lying about Russia to this man
Mike Pence aka Mike Pence
everybody lies about knowing kiss lyac
except the fat donny who invites him
right into the Oval Office to yuk it up
the day after he fired this man FBI
director James Jimmy the giant Comey aka
the boy scout aka the election [ __ ]
who had been investigating the whole
mess it all adds up the only thing we
don't have is a confession when I
decided to just do it I said to myself I
said you know this Russia thing with
Trump and Russia is a made-up story
Watergate was follow the money this case
is roll the videotape and it all points
to a Russian plot to degrade our faith
in democracy install a puppet state and
[ __ ] over an old enemy but hey I guess
it could be just a fat guy on his bed